[Musique]
james james brown
ça vous dit quelque chose
à feel good
cette personne est le père de la faune
qu elle influencera énormément de
courants musicaux des musiques dans mon
entier influencera aussi la street dance
ont fait un petit bond nous sort des
années 60 on arrive dans les années 70
dix ans après à travers une émission
fameuse qui s'appelle le sol traîne là
on y verra des groupes fameux de phong
et des danseurs qui se produiront et
partageront avec tout le monde leur
amour pour cette culture
je vous laisse découvrir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ça vous parle ça vous a plu
des petites images donc voilà on vient
de voir les membres d avec son netbook à
12 longueurs qui est le premier après ma
génération qui a développé ce style de
danse qui sera hyper populariser et qui
influencera jusqu'à nos jours
le style de danse danse hip hop des
fonks nice twitter
[Musique]
une figure incontournable dans le monde
du vous parle je pense que vous avez
déjà vu ça mais marceau tout le monde et
j'avais des petites images
voilà une baffe caricature en tout cas
voilà on revient sur roberts qui est lui
pareille à développer cette discipline
des années sans titre jusqu'aux années
80 un niveau vraiment un niveau très
fort et il influencera aussi la street
dance à son époque
en même temps de l'autre côté en europe
un courant musical électronique
s'installe donc raptor kuhn group bah je
sais pas c'est au bout du quai faire
aussi donc voilà c'est un des textures
sonores qui deviennent de plus en plus
froide synthétique industriel vous
laisse découvrir ça
[Musique]
voilà pour cette immersion dans le monde
de la faune de la street dance la sole
c'était un petit peu confie mais voilà
l'élément qui m'a permis m'a permis de
m'en inspirer
au fil de ces années donc voilà
apparemment je suis le dernier
donc c'est cool je vous un par région
vous inviter à ajouter un petit peu ce
monde-là levé vous tous sans exception
tout le monde y aura droit au caire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]